[Música]
ah
con el gusto de siempre los saludamos en
su programa canadá en las américas café
el castor cibernético con esas imágenes
de todas las regiones de canadá les
damos la bienvenida a donde quiera que
se encuentran a este su programa canadá
en las américas café estamos aquí en los
estudios de montreal los saluda paloma
martínez y aquí en el estudio está en
leonora chapman
pablo gómez barrios del equipo
latinoamericano de radio canadá
internacional como están gozando de este
fresco eso es una forma también en el
estudio una invitada especial es paulina
ya la es candidata del partido del nuevo
partido democrático de canadá en la
circunscripción de 6 michel como ésta
paulina bienvenida a canadá en las
américas o las radios soy la candidata
barcelonesa michelena 0 chelsea y el
nombre completo de las circunstancias y
vio contenta la invitación no es la
primera vez que estoy acá en radio
canadá
qué bueno que todavía está un programa
hispanófono porque sabemos que con los
cortes de buche de presupuesto
la televisión pública y seguimos cada
semana a nuestros oyentes lo saben
estamos aquí para presentarles este
programa hoy en el programa tenemos
varios temas tenemos realidad virtual
tenemos también noticias de de ecuador
no de bolivia en este caso porque hay
elecciones en bolivia este fin de semana
tenemos también noticias sobre desde
praga
con una sorpresita desde praga de la
república checa pero vamos a empezar con
la entrevista con nuestra invitada
especial paulina ayala como decíamos
ella es ahora candidata para la
circunscripción de leonard 6 michel de
aquí de montreal pero ella fue miembro
del parlamento canadiense de otras por
otra circunscripción honorem
entre 2011 y 2015 por el nuevo partido
democrático y en el 2015 justamente
perdió ante otro latinoamericano
entonces no podemos quejar
por latinoamericanos el único
latinoamericano en el parlamento ahora
mismo digo pablo rodríguez del partido
liberal usted nació en santiago de chile
vive aquí en canadá desde los años 90 a
finales de los años 90 son novia 5
lamentó el referéndum exactamente llegó
en el año de referendo aquí en la ciudad
de montreal porque presentarse como
candidata nuevamente paulinas qué tal
que tanto que tantas buenas experiencias
le dejó digamos haber sido miembro del
parlamento en una cuestión que vaya a
una buena experiencia el hechor sido
diputada se porque desde mi juventud en
chile durante la dictadura yo siempre
luché contra esa dictadura en el
movimiento la no-violencia actividad y
fue muy duro y yo soy una mujer que cree
que los partidos políticos son solamente
un medio para construir la democracia
porque mis valores más profundos son la
democracia la libertad y la equidad
social y siento que si bien en canadá es
un país muy rico igual hay un
desequilibrio igual hay sectores de
pobreza hay racismo y discriminación
mira todo lo que ha pasado con los
pueblos autóctonos entonces siento que
la justicia uno la puede crear a partir
el parlamento federal hay todo un
trabajo que se hace a la internacional y
por eso es que yo juega un rol bastante
importante en lo que es para américa a
todo lo que tiene que ver con el
atropello que hacen las compañías
canadienses en nuestra américa porque
con los tratado de libre comercio el
empleo siempre ha criticado que nunca ha
habido una ley para proteger a esos
países a los trabajadores de esos países
con normas al nivel canadiense entonces
nos encontramos con compañías
canadienses que van a contratar sicarios
en colombia por ejemplo cuando fui y
bueno hay otras situaciones más entonces
no lo hago porque fuera una experiencia
al contrario fue duro fue difícil fue el
tiempo de los conservadores lo hago
porque yo creo en la causa entonces el
empleo del país que se acerca más a mis
valores porque un partido
socialdemócrata y el liberal para mí es
muy difícil por cuando yo llegué a este
país fue el año referéndum y se tapó
todo el escándalo las comandita entonces
yo digo no escuchar a un pueblo utilizar
un poco ese escándalo porque la gente
que nos sigue nos sigue en américa
latina pero bueno el año 125 cuando fue
el referente un café en que ve que lo
que pudieron por la nada
yo supe después que bolso salió en todas
las noticias que un fraude electoral en
sentido de como actualización de dineros
de todos los canadienses con fines
partisanos y eso es inaceptable yo me yo
luché contra una dictadura
y porque deje chile 95 por quienes
decepciones porque ese un país que sigue
siendo neoliberal y un país en donde la
política no existe el voto proporcional
en chile y yo dije ya le editó mis años
de juventud me quieran el cox ya pata de
la policía mi hermano estuvo preso
estuve muchos funerales de jóvenes
estudiantes que no quiero tener hijos en
chile porque chile tiene el mismo
problema que tiene mucho nuestra américa
latina es el clasismo endémico que es un
cáncer en nuestras sociedades y ustedes
verán no soy rubia no tengo los ojos
azules y no tengo una familia rica vengo
de una familia clase más allá media que
se empobreció en la dictadura entonces
dije no quiero tener hijos acá me viene
a estudiar y en francés se dice que para
más
rampage me lavaron quiere cual tengo
tres hijos grandes ahora
y dije bueno tengo que hacer algo en
este país y a partir del porque uno
podría implicarse a nivel provincial
planilla el federal tú puedes ayudar al
resto a américa porque canadá es parte
de américa americano es eeuu y canadá
tiene un rol que jugar en la política
exterior con respecto a latinoamérica
mira se le dificulta el acceso a los
venezolanos a los mexicanos para el
refugio político y mira lo que se está
viviendo en esos países entonces creo
que tengo ese rol que jugar como
latinoamericana
si me preguntaba cómo se define el
trabajo que uno hace en el para una vez
que ingresa al parlamento canadiense en
este caso se definen por comisiones como
un poco funciona eso es decir ustedes a
usted le interesa en tanto que
canadiense latinoamericana le interesa
me doy cuenta las relaciones canadá
américa latina es que usted puede
decidir que va a entrar en ese comité o
como cómo funciona no estoy al tanto por
eso le premiado no está fantástico
bastaría que señaló los colegios soy
profesor de historia
lo que pasa en el parlamento cuando
fuimos elegidos con jack layton el de
críos o lo que se dice el gabinete
fantasma
la posición oficial y así de nombre
por aron portavoz de américa y asuntos
consulares y una vez que se enfermó en
el partido me sacaron nosotros
consulares pero me dejaron américa y él
y el partido está el jefe decidía qué
comité trabajar todos en asuntos
extranjeros y él me metió en asunto
extranjero luego con cuando él desde
murió ya me metieron en otros comités
pero por mi parte tú tienes el derecho a
ser parte del panel américa que es una
organización parlamento intra
parlamentaria de parlamentario a todo
américa y es una opción personal
yo era miembro del consejo
administración y por eso que fui a haití
no hay tiene invitar un haití haití a
venezuela paraguay y cuando fui a
colombia fue porque me invitaron los
sindicalistas canadienses irlandeses e
ingleses y ahí trabajamos música
me llama la atención de cualquier manera
que no que no haya vivido esto como una
buena experiencia y de alguna manera es
un gran privilegio ser un representante
de la población en el parlamento
canadiense me llama la atención que no
haya sido una pena en el molde anterior
al interior hay muchos egos hay mucha
gente que está en el que conduce
transforman en diputados se olvidan que
son para servir que su patrón es el
pueblo la gente y hay algunos que se
suben y se ponen a lo creo que eso es un
problema planetario
en realidad es una realidad no es una
realidad siempre lo que los que están en
el imagínate para que las mujeres
accedan a los puestos del poder en el pp
siempre ha puesto mitad hombre y mitad
mujeres se le criticaba mucho que no
tenía todos sus candidatos diputados
porque estaba buscando la paridad pero
al interior tuve fuerzas súper es muy
frustrante yo presenté un proyecto de
ley sobre el solo impacto de las islas
de calor es bastante lo la salud los
canadienses
y eran no tenía sentido su argumento que
no creía en la crisis climática pero por
otro lado dentro de tus mismos equipos
de la gente que quieren más que quiere
aparecer latín porque le pasa a la
pregunta a ella yo quiero la mira aquí
es importante que hagamos las cosas
juntos pero eso sean todos los partidos
y no como te explica que hayan echado la
ministra a la justicia en el partido
liberal porque yo soy como un ser libre
en ese sentido yo soy capaz de hacer la
crítica y hay ciertos sectores que creen
que cuando que tú eres un soldado yo no
soy un soldado para ti tengo una
pregunta para hacerle un poco usted está
representando a una circunscripción
particular aquí en montreal podría
describir nos un poco qué tipo de gente
vive en esas iguanas o hice una
circuncisión maravillosa maravillosa
para mí porque me gustan los desafíos
una circunscripción donde hay mucha
pobreza entonces como en pd hay muchos
desafíos importantes de una
circunscripción es sobre todo la parte
de esas michella en donde hay mucha
gente que no son ni siquiera residente
están con estatuto precario hay falta de
es abordable a inmigrantes en esa es un
favor hay que preguntarse si hay que
adecuarse
en realidad la población mayoritaria
solo italiano pero que son italianos de
edad y los arrendatarios son los árabes
porque yo digo árabes porque ser
musulmán o no musulmanes que son el
segundo grupo población más importante
luego está la población haitiana que hay
muchos que están en situación precaria
en demanda de refugio luego está la
población latinoamericana y así tienes
una diversidad y entre ese grupo están
los que me cual entonces hay una
diversidad hay todo un problema de
acceso al empleo de equivalencia de
estudio de racismo fíjate que si usted
escuchen las noticias van a ver que una
persona fue asesinada en un pub piensa
leonard porque hay delincuencia entonces
también hay otras cosas
vivir en dos comunidades no no te dices
porque para mí es interesante si y ccoo
y como política yo quiero mejorar la
calidad y a la gente porque yo te digo a
mis chicos yo me los llevaba al parque
salón ar
un poco
porque tú me contaste porque para mí es
interesante entonces como
socialdemócrata es interesante porque
hay tan mis desafíos y para mí la
política son los desafíos porque si me
daba una circunscripción super cool muy
gran desafío para mí no es una es un
lugar donde tú vas a los parques son
maravillosos están adaptados para la
familia los organismos comunitarias
tienen locales es muy baja la clase que
tú no encuentra el ritmo porque subió a
unos padres a leonard en los hierros en
un borroso mont no tenemos organismo no
tiene biblioteca no tenemos lcd no
tenemos muchas cosas es a leonard es
hermoso pero andate a sam mitchell y tu
pasa una calle no hay ni un árbol hay
islas de calor entonces hay que trabajar
y ese es nuestro desafío en política yo
tengo una pregunta con contó este
impulso con toda la energía que se ve en
la persona política como segundo para
matizar familia está fue durísimo
mientras la diputada carlota chilena
[Música]
estaba mirando tierra
está en ottawa
como se dice acá mama pool yo fui estas
mamás hablar es muy protectora si yo fui
de estas madres que quien envía a los
niños a la guardería y yo cielo y odia
la universidad la noche les hacía el
puré y todas esas cositas y quien les
vale que los amamanta y que y que se
ocupa de todo y fueron la escuela en la
escuelita está tome cuando escuela
pública ojos a la escuela personalizada
esto pasa son donde la mamá súper
implica pero bueno si quieres esto
ciertamente el tiempo y para mis hijos
fue duro porque la mamá que estaba
siempre ahí ya no estaba y el papá y
papá papá no entendía y ver quién es
divorcio se divorcia la pareja ustedes
cuando vivía era diputada vivía en
ottawa
el diputado de ottawa tiene que ir
cuatro semanas sobre cinco a ottawa
hace una semana estaba en montreal una
semana y cuando te digo cuatro semanas
sobre 5
a viernes o de líneas a jueves de luna
en el mejor de los casos yo tomaba el
tren para estar cerca de mis hijos yo
podía tomar el tren de las 11 de la
noche para llegar tardísimo porque yo
quería estar con ellos en el desayuno
bueno eso al final te quema mucho al si
se me desgaste mucho entonces ahora todo
ganar con cuidado y aún así con todas
esas dificultades y todo quiere volver
al parlamento de canarias porque porque
hay cosas que no voy a volver a hacer
todas estas invitaciones de cócteles que
te hacen que tú sientes obligada y la
gente tu persona la gente tiene que ir a
este cóctel de esta comunidad esto nada
no eso es pérdida de tiempo pero en
cambio el hecho de hacer las peticiones
instalada afuera los supermercados
incluso en invierno para que la gente
votara firmar a las peticiones etc eso
así lo hago ir a afuera de los colegios
a ver a los padres en mil estamos
luchando para que baje la tasa interés
de las cartas de crédito que es un
proyecto del empleo después de la época
de jack layton 6% eso si tuviera
cócteles que estas dos horas sentadas
[Música]
y ahora las obligaciones familiares me
imagino que son distintas
entonces ahora sí puedes ir con más
libertad te sientes más libre es
regresar a la política y además que en
2008 yo no esperaba ganar yo estaba en
el university con una circunscripción
liberal yo no gané ganó jack layton y en
eso hay que ser humilde
entonces
y yo no sabía de la noche una mañana yo
estaba enseñando a rigurosa
murialdo y mis alumnos leían en las
bancas que a ganar entonces me asusté
como profesora les dejé todo preparado
el material chicos están felices me
presenté incluso a clase al otro día y
el director había encontrado ya una
suplen un soplón como se le ocurre
trabajar botón mis niños son la luz y
para mí fue difícil esa parte yo llamada
todos los días la nube la noche mis
hijos de corazón político cuál fue el
cambio de los dos jefes del que falleció
y del que está ahora
el cambio sería más bien qué pasó con
cualquier fin que es el que les sucedió
a los seis se hizo un trabajo
extraordinario en el parlamento como
también como un cuarzo en la puerta a la
gente al ver está claro por eso encontré
horrible no tuvimos derecho a usar todos
los militantes tenías que ir a alberta
pagarte el billete de avión para votar
como delegado
para decir que no dije que no hizo un
buen trabajo hablando sino el tipo por
favor logró sacar a los conservadores
pero ya meet in y jack layton tiene
muchas cosas en común como que habla de
la inteligencia a nivel cognitivo no es
cierto pero tienes la inteligencia
emocional guau
es impresionante porque cuando tú ves
el recorrido de día de crédito viene una
familia jack layton fue el gran líder
del nuevo partido democrático y que
falleció hace cuánto tiempo que falleció
el 22 de agosto el 2011
triste y jangeet singh le tocó una vida
muy dura muy dura cada hijo de un padre
médico que luego cayó en el alcoholismo
entonces tu familia perdió todo y si era
chico el hijo mayor bueno que es que
lucha que lucha que lucha apoyando a la
madre muy pareció lo que dio muchos
latinoamericanos en nuestro país en
madres que están ahí que se apoyan en el
hijo mayor de un abuso sexual incluso el
su profesor de taiwán do y así todo con
todas esas heridas él ama a su familia y
cuando la gente lo ataca dice te deseo
amor y te lo dice sinceramente yo cuando
lo digo en la primera vez yo lo agarré
por la espalda como de joven yo lo
agarro como yo fuera una mamá a mi jefe
y se da vuelta y estaba feliz en ningún
momento como feliz nos pusimos a bailar
en un parque y cuando ves lo y cuando
fuimos una actividad financiamiento él
llegó dijo cuánto paga
ustedes por venir a este cóctel nada
porque yo le dijo prefiero gente que
haga viene volado a que estén pagando
grandes sumas y dijo yo digo para vos
eso es lo que necesitamos política y esa
humanidad la comparten los bueno paulina
ustedes nuestra última candidata porque
hemos estado presentando a lo largo de
las últimas semanas a varios candidatos
tuvimos a juan vázquez del partido verde
tuvimos un clip habló estuvo conversando
con la candidata
martínez cerrada esperada y bégar dio
liberal también conversas te con osvaldo
núñez un viejo de la vieja época
y ahora usted perderá lo que como el
bloque en una candidata chilena también
exactamente nos contaba usted hace un
evento y usted es la representante del
nuevo partido democrático le deseamos a
todos los latinoamericanos pero esta
empresa habla de la dirección de metro
nacional valencia sus partidos y
representantes de américa latina
yo lo fui de esa manera porque incluso
cuando gane me llamaron la reunión con
chileno
me dijeron que vamos a hacer por
nosotros cómo lo vas a representar usted
no los pudo representar yo revisión toda
la gente en la circunstancia exactamente
pero como latinoamericana me los voy a
jugar y por eso es que hice un proyecto
de ley sobre el día del heritage
latinoamericano que no pasó la primera
lectura y cómo se cerró el parlamento
cayó al agua pero esos proyectos ley se
guardan en un bolsito y este año y lo
pasó otra candidata a otro partido
porque eso se hace ya tomar los
proyectos de ley que es fantástico
exactamente entonces muchas gracias por
haber dado nuestro estudio y a todos los
candidatos latinos que le estamos
presentando aquí pues buena suerte
buenas elecciones desgracia
gracias paulina y nosotros continuamos
tenemos para pasar para hacer la
transición el vídeo a mensajito
la aplicación bueno tenemos aquí la
gente que nos sigue en directo por
facebook daniel camporini saludos desde
mi internación hospitalaria si esta vez
es cierto si ésta
internado bueno que no está triste ando
y está mirando nos así que pronto y que
no recupere esa diosa no el sos a los
liberales van a perder por el doble
discurso y se han buscado dar la
elección de honestidad y estado de
derecho a otros países mientras éstas
protegen prácticas corruptas en sus
multinacionales cuando están cuando
éstas hacen negocios en el tercer mundo
eso le dicen no el xhosa bien abril dice
por fin hace un rato que no escuchaba el
programa en directo un placer estar acá
sí señor a la orilla del mar pablo te
queda muy bien la bufanda gracias y
enhorabuena por la calidad de su trabajo
gilberto martínez dice saludos desde
nicaragua
gustavo lucas algunos de nuestros y top
fun dice saludos antes de la ciudad de
melo departamento de cerro largo en
uruguay y dice se viene las elecciones
también en uruguay y argentina el gol y
de domingo 27 de octubre así cada
elección
américa un montón de países entonces
bueno muchas gracias ronaldo por esto
muchas veces a todos ustedes por
seguirnos a través de facebook live y
nos pueden seguir enviando mensajes a lo
largo del programa así que no no nos
abandonen porque aquí estamos todos un
ratito más y ahora sí vamos a ver el
vídeo de la aplicación que leonardo va a
explicarnos nuevamente porque esa
aplicación ya queremos que todos la
tengan entonces que todas trabajen es
mucho más rápido que nuestro lugar
digamos nuestro sitio internet
es decir a todo o play store para la
gente que usa android y bajar nuestra
aplicación les recomendamos que bajen la
versión en español pero tiene la
posibilidad viajarán de bajarla en
francés en inglés y en otras lenguas en
mandarín también la historia es que la
recomendamos con muchas ganas la
aplicación porque realmente es mucho más
rápido que el sitio de internet
uno puede guardar los temas que le
gustan o puede ampliar el tamaño de las
letras como puede ver este vídeo si uno
quiere puede ir y ver el vídeo de esta
edición habrá granma en vivo y después
queda por supuesto los archivos así que
pueden ir a consultar también durante el
momento que sea digamos en el archivo de
la aplicación así que recomendada en
appstore o en google play y si ponen el
radio canadá internacional español sale
en nuestra aplicación y si no para que
los que no tengan la posibilidad
buscarlo directamente en
en las tiendas a la derecha abajo en
nuestro sitio está el link para ella yo
quiero hacer un sondeo rapidito así con
las personas que están en este momento
en línea que nos digan quiénes han
bajado la aplicación así que les está
gustando
[Risas]
cuando yo les dije que tenía una
sorpresa desde praga
esta semana me lo de chico siempre
recordará el checo acosta
[Risas]
tuve estos días
bueno pues de un oyente nuestro un fiel
oyente nos dice el homero mendizábal nos
envió un mensaje
primero esta semana nos envió un mensaje
pidiéndonos que habláramos de las
elecciones en bolivia que son este
domingo 20 de octubre pero también nos
mandó un día llegó le dijimos mándanos
un vídeo yo no sabía que estaba en praga
entonces miren este mensaje que nos
envió
hola amigos de radio canadá soy
homero transmitiendo desde praga
república checa
soy un radioyente muy frecuente de sus
programas y también los leo bastante y
escucho y veo su transmisión el judías
viernes que transmiten en vivo
aquí atrás mío se encuentra el castillo
de praga que es la representación más
famosa que existe en el país y al lado
mío está el río moldava como lo pueden
ver y en 2d barquitos no surgió bastante
famoso no porque cruza toda la ciudad
y bueno también contarles de que en una
semana el 28 de octubre se celebra 101
años de la fundación de checoslovaquia
y este sábado 20 de octubre también
informarles de qué son las elecciones en
bolivia
y yo voy a viajar hasta berlín para dar
mi voto en la embajada de bolivia
saludos desde praga a todos allá
yo tengo una pregunta antes que se me
olvide porque va a berlín a votar y no
la embajada boliviana en chequia
reportaje me gustó mucho así que muchas
gracias o menos por este mensaje también
por hacernos hablar de las elecciones en
bolivia porque hemos hablado poco
entonces pablo preparó una noticia si
tienen o no tenemos bolivia argentina
uruguay canadá
fiesta fiesta de elección entonces para
lo estuvo preparando aún un reportaje
noticia sobre las elecciones en bolivia
así es paloma entonces digamos que esté
en estas elecciones que se llevan a cabo
el próximo domingo 20 de octubre hay
nueve candidatos que se presentan de los
cuales
se destacan que es el actual presidente
de bolivia evo morales que se presenta
para un cuarto mandato y el ex
presidente de bolivia carlos mesa que
fue presidente entre el 2003 y el 2005 y
que les tocó renunciar porque pareció
que le pasó algo un poco parecido a lo
que le pasó a lenin moreno en ecuador
aumentó el precio de los hidrocarburos y
bueno en ese momento hubo
manifestaciones de tal forma que lo
pusieron entre la espada y la pared y
carlos meza tuvo que renunciar tuve que
renunciar además después de una serie de
represión costó la vida a más de 70
personas en ese momento en lo que se
conoce como la guerra del gas etcétera
entonces también mesa está muy
identificado con ese ciencia más acá y
aún así él es el más digamos el
candidato de la oposición que tiene más
chances de
hacerle una buena lucha a evo que se
está presentando para este cuarto
mandato
evo morales que como ya sabemos ha hecho
lleva ya 14 años en el poder
y que a ellos mucho también por bolivia
él desde que evo está en el ex
presidente de bolivia bolivia ha
conocido el mayor crecimiento de su
historia
así además invirtió mucho dinero en
programas que han sacado de la pobreza a
tres millones de personas entonces en la
actuación de evo como presidente pues ha
sido bastante benéfica si no podemos
decir así para bolivia un país que en
otros tiempos fue conocido como el país
que más golpes de estado había tenido o
sea que era algo completamente no me
recuerdo exactamente la cifra peruana
como 200
desde que existía como como país sólo
para ser sólo para agregar un poquito lo
que estás diciendo eso desde la del
crecimiento de bolivia de la economía
boliviana esta semana salió un informe
de la cepal donde decía que la economía
en el 2018 es ir en el 2010
hasta fin de año que tendría un
crecimiento de hasta el 4 por ciento que
es muchísimo y es más que chile y que
perú es decir eso está demostrando que
bolivia el plan económico que implementó
morales él tiene pues muchísimo
muchísimo éxito y la pobreza esto lo
dice el banco mundial también sacó era
60 por ciento de la población de la
pobre cuando asumió evo morales logró
reducir según el banco mundial
cifras oficiales del 60 por ciento abajo
a 30 por ciento
muchísimo una actuación muchísimo mejor
que de muchísimos otros presidentes y en
américa aún así la gente mucha gente no
está de acuerdo con que se presente una
cuarta vez como eso sí sí se puede se
puede porque se cambió la constitución y
eso le permite poder presentarse exacto
puede presentarse todas las veces que
quiera si la gente sigue votando por él
ahora
para estas elecciones si pierde pierde
que no se puede volver a presentar si
puede intentarlo nuevamente pero para
estas elecciones pues ha habido digamos
que un buen trabajo entre comillas de
parte de la oposición y evo que está
contando para estas elecciones con 30
por ciento de las intenciones de voto en
la actualidad cuando en las elecciones
pasadas contó con 54 por ciento en las
intenciones de boston y ahora 30 por
ciento tiene 30 por ciento y carlos meza
cuenta con 27 por ciento entonces les
viene mordiendo los talones así que no
se sabe todavía cómo va a salir cuál va
a ser el resultado de estas elecciones
lo que dices los analistas un poco
justamente poniendo todas esas cifras
que vos estás diciendo pablo es que en
estos momentos puede juzgar a favor de
evo morales lo que está sucediendo en
ecuador en argentina donde el fondo
monetario internacional se metió
nuevamente a nuestros países y estamos
viendo los resultados entonces eso
podría tal vez influenciar en el voto
y en argentina donde en el financial
times que es un diario global de la
economía
que publicó un artículo sobre macri que
le dio cero de basta con todas
devastador entonces bueno para terminar
paloma te diría que este hay un fuerte
dispositivo de seguridad en torno a
estas elecciones en bolivia se que dice
acá que hay 20 mil 871 policías que van
a estar presentes y que van a garantizar
la nada que es que no haya desmanes y
además de ese dispositivo están las
fuerzas armadas que por su parte
despliegan 11.171 soldados entonces nada
más para completar eso y en relación con
este último punto que tocas pablo l el
gobierno canadiense
la representación canadiense en bolivia
dijo que las elecciones presidenciales
que tendrán lugar el 20 de octubre
porque ese día perdón no se permitirá
que ningún vehículo circule por las
carreteras a menos que se le haya
concedido
previamente un permiso especial para
hacerlo hablan de hablan de las
precauciones que la gente debe tomar si
está en bolivia y entonces las
representaciones canadiense están
tomando están avisando a todos los
canadienses que se encuentran en ese
lugar que no hagan movimientos en falso
entonces bueno pues muchas gracias para
mí por por hablarnos de este tema además
gracias a homero por habernos hecho
pensar presentarse aquí en el programa
tenemos mensajes no mensajes dice se
desarrolló dicha radio si hace rato baje
la aplicación lo tengo y me gusta mucho
la categoría y que nos responda a la
pregunta que le hicimos que dice gracias
la cirugía fue exitosa y todo mejor
que se recupere lo más pronto posible
daniel miriam alarcón y sis lo baje la
aplicación me gusta pero lamentablemente
estoy haciendo una tesis y no tengo
tanto tiempo como me gustaría para
leerlos y verlos pero comentar ya
algunas notas estas semanas que te así
se está haciendo
si estás haciendo
leonora homero mendizábal dicen no hay
embajada de bolivia en república checa
homero mendizábal y sé gonzalo sánchez
fue el presidente cuando ocurrió esa
masacre hablando de lo que comentábamos
recién sobre las elecciones cuando
carlos meza se alejó luego que pasaron
los asesinatos hay que recordar que 21
mil 921 el 02 del 2016 se hizo un
referéndum para que llevo no pueda
postularse y él finalmente por si lo
hizo daniel camporini nos pregunta si
bolivia está bien porque tantos
bolivianos son ilegales en argentina
buena pregunta
gustavo luca ya tengo la aplicación dice
es muy práctica la recomiendo la baja en
español gustavo tendría que voy a
trabajar con vosotros
bueno porque gustavo eso en sus casos
que habla otras lenguas
también consultas noticias y contenidos
en francés y en inglés todavía no hablo
árabe aunque veo el programa ver si en
dicho idioma por favor saludan a los
conductores que estarán en un rato más
en las ondas de radio qhana
internacional
miriam alarcón dice la presidencia de
evo morales es benéfica en la mayor
distribución de la riqueza eso es lo que
toda américa latina necesita desarrollar
es charly signo de pregunta gracias por
tu nota pablo sobre argentina que se
sepa lo que se pasa porque los
mendizales esperemos que esta vez sí se
respete el voto de los bolivianos ya que
el referéndum del 21 del 2006 no ha sido
respetado por el actual gobierno así que
esas son los comentarios de nuestra
gente en las redes sociales
cinco personas de los que estando en la
aplicación de 50 por ciento
y nos queda mucho tiempo más que para
presentar muy rápidamente les pido
brevedad en temas de la semana y después
la gente podrá ir a consultarlos con
mayor tiempo al sitio internet entonces
leonora esta semana nos hablaste de que
20 organizaciones canadienses expresaron
su solidaridad con los ecuatorianos
junto a otras 250 más del mundo entero
en el mundo exactamente ya estuvimos
conversando sobre esto justamente la
semana pasada donde había pues bastantes
manifestaciones en ecuador contra
medidas impuestas por el fondo monetario
internacional al presidente moreno entre
ellas la que hizo saltar a la gente fue
la eliminación de los subsidios a la
esencia de la presencia presencia de
perfume al combustible entonces lo que
ocurrió este fin de semana fue que el
presidente moreno derogó el decreto que
se lo conoce como 883 que eliminaba
justamente esto
entonces a partir de ese momento se
separó la represión se comenzó a
negociarse con su forma un comité para
ver cómo van a negociar los próximos
pasos que va a dar el gobierno respecto
a estas medidas y 100 25 organismos
canadienses o más de 20 por lo menos
junto con 250 organizaciones del mundo
entero firmaron una declaración para
expresar su solidaridad con apoyo a las
organizaciones indígenas laborales y
también campesinas que participaron en
las protestas nacionales ellos de entre
otras cosas estos organismos le piden
que se haga justicia a lo que sucedió
durante la represión en ecuador y
amnistía internacional dice que la oea
le exige el que la oea tiene que
exigirle a ecuador que lleve a cabo una
investigación exhaustiva sobre las
violaciones a los derechos humanos
cometidas en la represión durante las
protestas también la defensoría del
pueblo de ecuador dice que esta
represión
por el momento un saldo de ocho muertos
1200 detenidos en fin hubo muchísima
mucha bueno mucha represión y los
organismos canadienses también entonces
están en esta misma línea exigiendo
justicia y dicen que están alertas
también van a seguir de cerca la
situación de ecuador y como se están
negociando entre las comunidades
indígenas y campesinos con el gobierno
de el presidente moreno sobre las
promesas que hizo el presidente moreno
entonces en nuestro sitio internet
www.sprint.com cuentan todos los
detalles de la entrevista que hizo a
leonora y el reportaje que les presentó
al respecto de la de los organismos
canadienses pablo balón
esta semana nos presentaste un informe
sobre lo sobre el hecho de que los afro
canadienses los árabes y los indígenas
son mucho más susceptibles de ser
interceptados por la policía en montreal
que pasó así bueno lo que pasó es que
había digamos un cierto malestar en el
seno de las autoridades de la dirección
de la policía de montreal y con respecto
a este a éste a la actuación de los
policías y decidieron abrir su base de
datos a investigadores independientes
para que trataran de ver cuál es el
problema los hubo tres investigadores
entre los que se encuentra un argentino
el profesor de sociología en la
universidad de quebec en montreal víctor
ar bonnie y en la conclusión que los que
después del análisis de lo de las
informaciones que ellos estuvieron
revisando es que hay un sesgo étnico es
un sesgo racial en el seno de la policía
cuando detienen a las personas y que ese
sesgo se manifiesta sobre todo con las
los afro canadienses o las personas de
raza negra los árabes y los indígenas
entre otros en el caso de los
en el caso de los indígenas es cuatro
veces tienen cuatro veces puntos seis
más casi cinco veces más posibilidades
de ser detenidos que un blanco para los
para los los árabes es de 22 veces más y
para los negros es de 4.2 veces más
posibilidad americano bill así si tú
tienes pero según las cifras que estás
dando es que las primeras naciones y los
indígenas y los árabes y los negros son
los más
la policía que normalmente tiene que
defender y proteger así entonces muy
rápidamente te pueden escuchar la
entrevista en nuestro sitio pero lo que
decía entre otras cosas el informe de
estos tres expertos es que lo que no
pudieron establecer es la relación que
existe entre
este sesgo racial y el perfilado racial
si hay una diferencia en el sentido de
que ellos no lograron establecer si hay
una relación directa entre lo uno y el
otro que es decir te detienen porque
tienes cara de latino bueno al que tiene
la piel oscura tiene la piel oscura pero
al que es latino o al que es árabe oa
los indígenas cuáles son las razones por
las cuales no tienen acceso a esa
información
solamente tuvieron acceso a la parte a
la cuestión étnica la característica
étnica de la persona pero la base pero
sí pero qué es lo que motiva a la gente
de policía o la agente de policía es
decir a él yo le voy a pedir su papel y
su identificación bueno eso es lo que es
en nuestro sitio del reportaje en la
entrevista con víctor armonía gracias
pablo leonardo si los estos cascos de
realidad virtual no serán ya como los
los imaginamos con el teléfono aquí
pegados
hay gente que confundía y eso me llamó
la atención y por eso decidí hacer esta
nota tiene que ver con la desaparición
de uno de los primeros elementos que uno
usaba para la realidad actual para
conocerla qué es unos cascos donde nos
ponía el teléfono así estudiar con eso
tener un programa especial obviamente
una aplicación y hacer como que estaba
dentro de una cápsula de realidad
virtual y bueno este tipo de cosas nació
con eso que estamos viendo en pantalla
que son los campos
[Risas]
si lo hacemos con carbón
con cartón y estos fueron los primeros
donde uno ponía su teléfono podía
hacerlo y después salieron boom van un
poco más sofisticados y verán dos otras
empresas que los empezará a fabricar
pero la gente empezó a quejarse a
quejarse de que yo me tengo que conectar
esta tengo que hacer toda una historia
para poner el teléfono para conectar el
teléfono en modo virtual y cuando quiroz
al teléfono toque es armar todo eso
entonces uno de los dueños de la empresa
oculus que hace cascos de realidad
virtual es el que dijo esta semana sea
cárdenas ya no más con esto porque la
gente no lo quiere entonces están
desarrollando ellos y esta es la ventaja
para el ingeniero rolando que tiene todo
dentro del casco se mantiene que estar
conectado a una computadora sino con el
casco sólo podría entrar
está fotografiando lo encontró leonardo
lo encontré yo porque así me lo imagino
que van a hacerlo un día de ciencia
ficción en la tele o una película en la
que había uno de los actores que tenía
un algo parecido a la acción para ver si
mucho tiempo bueno esta semana si hay un
poco de tiempo si yo hice un reportaje
que me gustó hacer porque mails me llamó
la atención que había poca mención de
américa latina en las relaciones de
américa latina con canadá durante la
selección de la campaña electoral
entonces me interese en ese tema porque
canadá y américa latina tienen
relaciones diplomáticas económicas
políticas desde hace muchísimas décadas
y en la campaña electoral ha habido poca
digamos mansión poca mención entonces
estuve hablando con alguien del consejo
canadiense para la cooperación
internacional entre otros que nos dijo
sin alas los diferentes partidos
políticos tienen visiones muy distintas
con respecto a américa latina pero
todos los casos tienen que ponerle más
atención a lo que dijo el partido
conservador particularmente con respecto
al corte de la ayuda
al extranjero y donde no mencionó para
nada américa latina le preocupa mucho
este consejo porque dice van a cortar
los maravillosos programas que se han
ido instalando con dinero canadiense con
organismos latinos trabajando él había
cortado muchos programas en la época que
exactamente entonces en este reportaje
les hablamos de las diferentes posturas
de los partidos políticos con respecto a
américa latina en general y a la ayuda
internacional y a las posibilidades de
que si ganan cómo serán las relaciones
con américa latina entonces sabían el
sitio internet www.sprint.com más
información al respecto
llegó una una persona más allá la cabina
que no me dijo su nombre pero voy a
mencionar los que sabemos que están ahí
y preguntarle y le puedo preguntar su
nombre también h4
konami
y tal vez no puede decir que francis
está allí nos ayudó durante la parte en
la parte del sonido del audio pero
también tenemos a estuvo también pierde
y ésta pierde útil que es nuestro
ayudante de siempre en el lado del lado
de la cabina
gioja que controlan todas las cosas
maravillosas las imágenes y fans siendo
español
en español y entienden todo lo que
decimos muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado no generamos empleo cuatro
horas
hasta la próxima semana no se necesitó
internet libre w
un dolor steiner puntos chau
o no
a mí
[Música]